for five days she's been missing today
the search for British backpacker Amelia
bambridge moved inland the 21 year old
disappeared on the Cambodian island of
koh rong on wednesday her family scours
CCTV desperate for information
Amelia's father shows me her heading to
a beach party just before 2 a.m. she
doesn't return how helpful is this to
you is that giving you hope at least
that you're starting to build a timeline
yes do you found one in the darkness of
snippets of video catches Amelia on the
last night she was seen she seems happy
and relaxed at a party with friends but
she never returned to her hostel her bag
was later found abandoned on the beach
back in the UK her distraught sisters
wait for news she's two years older than
me and she's like my role model says
she'd always never drink to excess she's
always in control nod and I'd be like
following her she'd always be looking
out for me always looking after me and I
just it's just not like her to not look
after herself because she spent all of
my love life looking after me so I just
I just I just I just don't know what's
happened is after two days of searching
the beach authorities are now also
combing the islands thick jungle so
today what's your plan what are you
doing what we do today just try to
research in the chongo or obvious area
first and go to people's houses - and
the people have you been to the site
yesterday already searching the guests
how are baguettes how
everything they've been searching
through this jungle now for hours and if
Amelia is in here it's exceptionally hot
there are steep drops on either side
it's muddy she's no doubt going to be
dehydrated and the fear is she could
also be injured
it's supposed to be camera over there
with every passing day this family knows
the danger for Amelia is growing and
they're determined to do whatever it
takes to find her siobhan Robyn's Sky
News car on Cambodia